[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission ne pas manquer
si vous êtes un passionné de sport local
au programme aujourd'hui comme toujours
des analyses techniques des décryptages
et surtout une bonne dose de bonne
humeur pour m'accompagner nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous sur ce
plateau ils sont tous revigoré par les
premiers rayons de soleil du printemps
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite il nous vient tout droit des
contrées à versailles est ce jeune homme
toujours bien apprêtée est un passionné
de rugby dans cette émission le surnomme
le gladiateur pour son énergie qu'ils
déploient dans les duels pierre
chevalier du rugby-club de versailles
nous fait l'honneur de venir une
nouvelle fois dans cette émission
salut les amis pour aller vous plaire en
pleine forme le les rayons du soleil
sont vitales assez vite reparti la wii
aujourd'hui c'est ça que ça mais on est
bien dans studio on a eu chaud on est
aux jeunes à l'avancé son brin de soleil
soleil et et giboulées çà et là on
continue notre tour de table à gauche et
les journalistes chez tv 68 il est
expert sur le sport local mais
aujourd'hui c'est un petit italienne
lover que nous avons en face de nous ou
presque en deuil après la
non-qualification de l'italie à la coupe
du monde grégory canale a tout de même
tenu à être présents dans cette émission
bonjour grégory bonjour nickel dont jean
pierre bonjour à tous j'ai eu et j'ai
même gardé le masque pour masquer
justement un peu mes impressions alors
je me permet quand même de vous poser la
question est ce que vous allez bien ça a
été très dur après cette élimination de
l'italie mais le fait de retrouver la
team je n'avais pas participé à la
dernière émission c'est un peu une sorte
de thérapie je vais parler de sport de
sujets de beaux sujets aujourd'hui c'est
une sorte de thérapie pour aller mieux
et premier on parlera pas de plus paul
italien c'est josé versini alors on
continue notre tour de table musique
c'est un basketteur d'exception il a
joué aux quatre coins de l'europe il a
notamment joué avec l'équipe nationale
de la république centrafricaine il est
aujourd'hui au club de basket de trappes
il est toujours de bonne humeur magic
mike mokongo le fait l'honneur de venir
dans cette émission comment allez vous
ça va ça va très bien je suis content de
retrouver les copains et puis à beaucoup
de choses de quoi parlait donc donc
voilà je suis ravi d'être là parmi tous
toujours avec le sourire comme
d'habitude bien sûr la vie est belle et
fait beau comme vous l'avez dit prestbo
dans les studios
aujourd'hui
enfin notre dernier chroniqueur musique
c'est une légende vivante de ce talk eu
l'âme de cette émission il et blagueur
farceur taquin mais il est aussi un
tranchant dans ses allées et sportive
coach jo gomis ex-entraîneur de plaisir
sera avec nous pendant une heure
quand allez-vous genre il n'a pas tenu
celui la pression des émissions riches
et émergents santisteva michel dubaï
côté argent et j'aime pas résisté
en tout cas vous avez grégory à côté de
vous je compte sur vous pour l'épauler
un peu dans ses moments durs mais par
contre félicitations la l'italie qui
boycottent le qatar
alors on va passer au programme de
l'émission va parler des jo de 2024 à
paris on le savait tous les
organisateurs français voulaient des
jeux olympiques populaire avec notamment
une magnifique cérémonie d'ouverture sur
la scène qui devraient accueillir 600
mille spectateurs et on l'a appris en ce
mois de mars 10 millions de billets
seront mis en vente et un million de
billets seront disponibles au tarif de
24 euros et près de la moitié sont
disponibles à 50 euros ou moins la
question sur cette thématique est ce que
cela vous surprend ce tarif 24 euros un
million de billets à 24 euros oui ou non
où es tu donc pour vous pierre-louis
pour vous
mike du coup ça me surprend oui c'est ça
ou
alors mike ça vous surprend pas vous non
non ça me surprend pas ça me surprend
pas parce que s'il fallait que je
réponde peut-être pas
non il ya une volonté je pense
simplement de faire participer à tout le
monde cette occasion là qui est
magnifique pour le pour la france pour
le pays pour tous les sports et donc je
pense que tout à fait légitime de
pouvoir le faire dans ce sens aux gens
24 euros ce le bon tarif tarifs
accessibles en tout cas voilà le but
arrive je sais pas mais accessible voilà
oui c'est surtout c'est surtout le terme
qui vont retenir accessible et c'est
bien commun que commun dit mike c'est un
prix abordable et qui va populariser
l'événement notamment au niveau des
spectateurs qui va permettre à un nombre
supérieur de pouvoir venir au bord des
ddd stade et sur les terrains quoi le
risque c'est que le credo de ces jeux
c'est des jeux avant tout populaire un
thonier stangl a répété à de nombreuses
reprises président du comité
d'organisation 24 euros c'est aussi une
petite opération de com - les jo 2000
24,24 euros on est légèrement au dessus
par rapport à ce qui s'était fait à
tokyo sur le prix de base des billets
mais ça reste accessible jean l'a dit et
on est alors à londres pour donner
quelques chiffres allons les prix
allaient de 20 livres à
2292 livré pour les gros les gros
événements à le 100 m par exemple les
cérémonies d'ouverture et de clôture
c'était sensiblement les mêmes tarifs
prévus du coup à tokyo à rio s'était
légèrement moins cher on parle de 18
euros environ peut-être pour répondre
aussi à la population locale aux au
pouvoir d'achat la population locale
aussi adapté au pouvoir d'achat des
populations locales est effectivement et
voilà on sait que pour des géo réussi il
faut ce côté populaire qui est qui est
importantissime est d'ailleurs la même
philosophie a été adopté par les
organisateurs sur la cérémonie
d'ouverture où il y aura des places
payantes sur les quais bas de la scène
on rappelle que c'est une cérémonie qui
se déroulera en extérieur enfin à
l'extérieur d'un stade et ça c'est une
première dans l'histoire des jo une
cérémonie sur la scène et sur les quais
hauts les spectateurs aussi pourront
accéder gratuitement à cette cérémonie
donc on est un petit peu aussi dans
cette philosophie prônée par le comité
d'organisation il espère évidemment
qu'il fera beau lors de cette cérémonie
d'ouverture pas comme aujourd'hui
je trouve que le que le comité
d'organisation de paris de 1024 mo
frappé fort à plusieurs à plusieurs
égards et notamment sur le côté
effectivement le plus grand public et le
plus populaire possible c'est le retour
le des jeux d'été en france depuis un
grand nombre d'années même aussi les
clubs au siècle dernier cc c'est le
retour sur la patrie de pierre de
coubertin c'est aussi des jeux d'été
après quelques années très très loin de
la france notamment et de l'europe après
tokyo et tokyo et rio donc faire de
cette de cette manifestation une
manifestation populaire grand public
c'est de toute façon je pense l'essence
même du sport olympique et des sports
olympiques on a vu aussi malgré le mal
gré le
laos de des téléspectateurs des
retransmissions surtout les surtout les
diverses possibles et imaginables
quand c'est notamment concerts organisés
loin que rien ne remplace l'ambiance
d'un stade d'une cérémonie d'ouverture
qu'on veut en plus
grandiose total totalement original dans
un lieu totalement original et je pense
que pour justement pour porter ces
projets là il faut que ce soit
accessible 24 euros c'est 1 c'est un
tarif c'est plutôt un tarif bas par
rapport à ce qui se fait d'une manière
générale dans tous les sports dans tous
les sports dans les stades on sait que
on sait qu'après il faudra dépenser
peut-être d'autres peut-être d'autres
petites choses sur des ventes
additionnelles et ça c'est le business
model de france 2000 24 mai mais là en
l'occurrence je pense qu'il ne pouvait
pas faire autrement que de viser un élan
populaire et que cela soit suivi le plus
possible en france notamment parlé par
tous les français depuis la formation à
présent que vous avez précisé c'est
qu'il y aura la moitié des billets à 50
euros ou moins donc même sur sur les
chrétiens quand il ya une fourchette
largement accessible pour ces régions
est-ce que c'est pas aussi un intérêt
des organisateurs de remplir les stades
aussi on sait que par exemple à rio il y
avait eu près d'un million un million de
billets qui n'avaient pas trouvé preneur
des stades peut être un qui sonnait un
peu creux est ce que ce n'est pas aussi
dans leur intérêt et au niveau
télévisuel par exemple magny je pense et
puis même pour les athlètes c'est
quelque chose d'important il aime bien
en général avoir du monde dans les
stades donc donc forcément moi je pense
que c'est une volonté et puis ça leur
permettra aussi de pouvoir comme tout le
monde l'a pu dire sur le plateau
accéder à tous ces sports la profiter de
ces moments là parce que ça sera un
moment qui est incroyable donc je pense
est une bonne chose vous aimeriez
assister à quelles épreuves peut-être
gens on commence par vous
la gymnastique synchronisée
c'est tout non
vous avez eu droit à plusieurs à
plusieurs la grue puis à 7 quand même la
tête 10 le rugby à 7 est pour moi les
sports collectifs matière toujours plus
d'ailleurs je suis très content que le
basket ne se déroulera pas dans ce parc
des expositions porte de versailles
c'était un peu la voilà la polémique du
moment et ça on ne peut que s'en réjouir
on attend de voir où va se dérouler ce
tournoi préliminaire mais oui la finale
du 100 mètres en athlétisme c'est un
rêve un rêve de journalistes sportifs
d'enfants de voir cet événement après il
ya toutes les épreuves qui m'intéresse
mais une finale de 100 m c'est quelque
chose qu'on y sportif italien
sur les basketteurs qui a intérêt
intervenu par rapport à cette volonté de
ne pas accepter que le basket ball
depuis ces joueurs celui là je trouve
c'est très important pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui les les sportifs sont
maintenant acteurs de ce qui se passe
autour de leur sport et ça c'est très
important que s'en trouvera peut-être
dans cette compétition un peu plus tard
avec ian est un sportif et ça je pense
que c'est très important de voir rudy
gobert devoir
bonne journée à gérer ces sujets là une
épreuve de natation natation et parfois
l'yzf natation tout comme la natation
les erreurs de natation de vitesse audet
et le handball et le handball masculin
féminin parce que ça fait partie aussi
des sports où on a des choses des bonnes
chances de médailles d'or est pour vous
mike weir golfe j'ai envie de découvrir
d'autres sports donc le golf qui se
déroulera ici à saint quentin en
yvelines tu rappelles alors le début des
inscriptions en tout cas au tirage au
sort ce sera fin 2022 il ne faudra pas
rater à cette date 1 messieurs alors
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de killian mba paix at il
bien fait de boycotter certains sponsors
de l'équipe de france coup de projecteur
également sur la santé mentale des
sportifs valentin porte le handballeur
notamment parler de dépression suite au
départ de sa femme mais avant de parler
de ces thèmes on va parler rugby
[Musique]
on va tout de suite passé à l'envolée de
grégory on commence décidément très fort
cette émission de quoi allez vous nous
parlez à grégory une excellente nouvelle
qui je pense va ravir en plateau qui va
ravir un homme je le sais c'est
versailles et son complexe de
porchefontaine qui seront les camps de
base à 2 pays de galles pendant la coupe
du monde 2023 de rugby en france martyn
williams en personne de grand chelem on
le rappelle avec le quinze du poireau
meilleurs joueurs des six nations en
2005 3 mondiaux disputés à officialiser
ce partenariat avec la ville aux côtés
de françois de mazières le cliché qui
s'affiche à l'écran les gallois se
prépareront durant quatre semaines à la
coupe du monde au programme on le
rappelle en 2023 en france du 8
septembre au 28 octobre et il ya de quoi
être heureux eux pour plusieurs raisons
ça va faire monter en puissance
l'engouement autour de cet événement un
mondial en france où les bleus rappelons
le qui ont été étincelant depuis
plusieurs mois seront attendus et
soutenu on espère tout de même pour le
pays de galles 1 que les entraînements
seront ouverts au public quelques
entraînements et que les joueurs
pourront être approchés c'est une bonne
nouvelle aussi pour la ville de
versailles une ville de sport on l'a
rappelé souvent ici en plateau et
surtout une terre de rugby avec son fier
représentant pierre et est en plus en
plateau le rcv 129 ans d'histoire
septième club le plus vieux de france
rien que ça sa formation son équipe
fanion c'est aussi tout ce travail très
sérieux qui est récompensée et une
sélection britannique dans la cité
royale ça fait forcément écho à la venue
de l'angleterre en 2007 déjà pour la
coupe du monde le quinze de la rose
logeait au trianon palace et avait
préparé le mondial notamment avec un
entraînement au stade mont boron les
jeunes avaient pu approcher les
coéquipiers de jonny wilkinson s'était
blessé on le rappelle au début de la
préparation dans les yvelines mais l'air
versaillais avait résolument fait du
bien aux anglais qui s'était hissé
jusqu'en finale du mondial en éliminant
la france en demi espérons que le
scénario ne se répète pas pour les
gallois sinon il faudra interdire
définitivement aux équipes de venir se
préparer ici dans les yvelines alors
plus généralement les nations en rugby
ou même dans d'autres sports aiment
venir se préparer dans le département
très récemment pour l'euro de football
en 2016 l'irlande à à versailles aussi
mais aussi la russie du côté de croissy
sur seine et lors de la coupe du monde
féminines la ville de croissy sur seine
avait également accueilli les
championnes du monde américaines qui
était de passage dans la ville
yvelinoise en 2022 ça a été un peu
l'année du football surtout le le début
de l'année à versailles avec le parcours
du fcv en coupe de france 2000 23
peut-être l'année du rugby et enfin 2024
année olympique à versailles après la
période trouble du coc vide on peut dire
qu'on est gâtés est ce que cette venue
officialise versailles comme terre de
rugby vous votez oui ou non
oui pour vous cherche bien évidemment
pour vous évidemment
jambes on va faire un petit un petit
duel entre jean et pierre gens vont
commencer chimique entre jean-pierre
balle au centre
c'est oui c'est qu'un pur pour taquiner
un peu mon ami pierre je gémis nantes et
qu'il a mis oui alors sérieusement
c'est très très bien bien sûr que c'est
excellent excellent que que le pays de
galles prenne ses
marques à versailles et apport
chaudfontaine notamment bon après de là
à dire que ça devient par le fait
terrain de rugby non nous ne savons pas
quand même le rugby c'est un sud ouest
c'est pas à versailles mais c'est une
excellente publicité pour pour pour la
ville pour le club qui en pleine
ascension faut leur faut le rappeler
quand même que versailles brille en
fédérale 3 actuellement le club et va se
dirige je l'espère pour eux vers une
montée en fédérale 2 avec le jeu de
choses y voir justement
la nouvelle la nouvelle programmation de
la fédération dans les prochaine et donc
ça le fait que augmenté
l'importance que le rugby prend à
versailles avec cette venue du pays de
galles pour la coupe du monde c'est tout
beau tout bénef tout bénef tout bénef
mais alors c'est pas bien et ne lui font
pas peur de rugby les terres de rugby
sont dans le sud ouest 9 0 point
récemment on le précise
au moins avec mc a brillé avec quelques
me première victoire c'est tant pis elle
précisé et le 100 m est aussi italiens
aussi un jesus luz et santi a faim c'est
à leur reer qui joue à grenoble oui
handicap ou de à vos pierres évidemment
je ne pouvais pas répondre autre chose
que oui avec un petit bémol ou pour
aller quand même dans le sens de dans le
sens de l'histoire et dans le sens dans
le sens de janot c'est de dire que c'est
que versailles grâce au parcours
l'ensemble des sports est devenue une
terre de sport venir ont globalement une
terre de sport le trajet du scv en coupe
de france on en a suffisamment parlé sur
ce sur ce plateau et le trajet ou le
futur trajet du rugby-club versailles en
championnat france et puis et puis
justement éventuellement l étage à
l'étagé du dessus ce que l'on vise ce
que l'on vit cette saison ce qui est un
terrain intéressant de noter c'est la
raison qui a fait que les gallois ont
choisi les raisons qui ont fait que les
jeux et les gallois ont choisi
versailles comme camp de base est-ce que
ça va ce que ça va engendrer après la
raison avancée qu'on a malgré tout même
si elles sont insuffisantes à notre
à nos yeux le nombre d'installations
qu'il faut et des installations de
qualité avec un terrain synthétique un
terrain en herbe quand je dis
insuffisante c'est que pour un club de
plus de 600 licenciés parfois c'est
difficile de jouer à tetris pour mettre
toutes les catégories en même temps
notamment le mercredi notamment le
samedi quand il ya des plateaux de toute
l'école de rugby mais c'est versailles
ville de sport une ville où il fait bon
vivre agréable c'est ce qu'ils ont mis
en avant notamment aussi quasiment de
pouvoir aller sur toutes les
installations quasiment à pied je crois
que dans le cahier des charges c'est 20
minutes c'est 20 minutes pour pouvoir
être éligible pour y aller à pied
peut-être qu'on les verra déambuler dans
les dents les virées dans la ville de
versailles
des installations qui vont être
complétés ça ça me fait ça me fait
parler de ce qui va suivre après des
conséquences on a un cahier des charges
qui est quand même assez exigeant pour
être comme base sur le savoir on l'a on
n'y a eu accès pour la partie sportive
il ya un certain nombre de choses qui
vont devoir être mise à niveau taille de
terrain les installations une salle de
muscu donc temporaires les accès aux
piscines et aux espaces de récupération
ce qui va suivre derrière c'est
peut-être de la récupération de
structures temporaires ou définitives de
matériel et puis surtout ce qui va
suivre pendant c'est
ce qui va suivre pendant ces 10 et
surtout pour bien connaître de
l'intérieur la vie d'une équipe
internationale en coupe du monde que
j'ai eu la chance de travailler avec
l'équipe d'écossé en 2007
d'autres britanniques c'est c'est toute
l'animation que ça amène à versailles il
va y avoir
tout un des expressions passion autour
du rugby on va les voir dans la ville un
certain nombre d'événements qui sont
organisées tous les jours en plus du
sportif et puis oui c'est l'accès au
sport de haut niveau pour tous les
enfants versailles et tous les enfants
du club leurs familles tous les
versaillais qui ne connaissent pas
encore peut-être bien le rugby et qui
vont là aussi
permettre aux à versailles de devenir et
de vraiment s'installer comme terre de
sport après lé terre de rugby
historiquement parce qu on est sur place
depuis 1893 mais c'est vrai que
culturellement c'est parce que les
anglais ont traversé la manche et ceux
qui ont choisi versailles après en
france c'est effectivement c'est un peu
plus au sud
mike et qui vous a convaincu
non je pense que les deux arguments se
valent 1 après moi j'allais répandent un
petit peu pareil que j'en ai puisque l'a
dit pierre aussi c'est assez cohérent
c'est vrai que c'est pas une terre
forcément de rugby mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que les gens aiment le rugby dans
la région a pris à une volonté du club
de se professionnaliser de faire grandir
ce club là donc c'est une semaine très
belles choses et je pense qu'aussi le
partenariat avec le pays de galles c'est
une très bonne chose pour la génération
du club de versailles pourquoi parce que
c'est un monument pour le monde de rugby
et pays de galles donc dû de ce fait là
ça leur permettra justement oui c'est
pas une petite équipe légale parce qu'il
aurait pu avoir une équipe un peu plus
confidentielle là c'est vraiment un
poids lourd exactement et ça leur
permettra justement d'avoir des échanges
justement sur plusieurs aspects sur
l'aspect terrain en dehors comment les
choses se font pour amener un club comme
versailles un très haut niveau donc je
pense ça peut être que bénéfique pour le
club ait commencé à se presser au niveau
des installations pendant cette période
ça va être le tetris est encore plus
important des problèmes des problèmes du
cahier des charges c'est
qu'effectivement il faut mettre à
disposition les terrains les terrains du
club qui ne seront pas forcément
accessibles tous au public juste public
et encore moins encore moins en
pratiquant donc là on va faire un petit
rappel à nos petits camarades des
yvelines et d'île de france pour faire
des échanges de terrains et pour pour
aller un petit peut être être un peu
nomade comme la comme l'a été le stade
français en son temps
cherchez des stades mais il ya lui
verser le rck fut une journée qui est
devenue versé 78 et le sky et anti
bretons là où ils ont eu deux trois
stades s'est amusé de belles
installations voilà au chesnay au génial
c'est ça oui ça fait partie de 2,2 du
revers de médaille il faudra trouver des
solutions en europe mais pour avoir
discuté avec martyn williams à l'épaule
street jeunes qui étaient là la
délégation qui est venu officialiser le
choix auprès du de françois de mazières
maire de versailles ils sont très très
positifs à la britannique c'est vraiment
vraiment très très arrangeant je pense
que d'une manière générale on pourra
trouver avec eux et la vie la ville
pourra trouver avec eux des modules juin
10 qui me permettront de malgré tout
continuer parce que parce qu'on devine
23 ans sera théoriquement
on sera en sera à un bon niveau et
septembre c'est un pour toutes les
catégories ce timbre chargé est ce que
votre avis la venue de l'angleterre en
2007 à jouer peut-être dans le choix
grégory après les halles elle et elle
est lointaine mais sans doute que oui
dans la capacité à recevoir une équipe
de ce niveau là parce que l'angleterre
aussi c'est pas une petite nation du
rugby c'est peu de le dire et à l'époque
ça s'était très bien déroulée le
parcours l'angleterre je les ai rappelés
dans l'envolée a été magnifique juste
après peut-être que la préparation dans
les yvelines a joué quelque peu même si
au tout début il y avait une entorse à
la cheville pour wilkinson donc ça ça
démarrait pas sous les meilleurs
auspices mais versa il ya une renommée
mondiale voilà grâce à son château il
n'y a pas que le château à versailles
mais ça fait partie de cette renommée
mondiale il avait logé au trianon palace
donc peut-être que ça a joué aussi dans
l'expérience qu'a cette ville de
versailles pour accueillir ce genre d
qui justement où ils le seront ils
logeront au trianon palace où on ne le
savait pas encore si un cheval et non ça
se joue entre nous deux c'est un peu le
lieu un peu habitué à recevoir les
grosses équipes l'angleterre en 2007 ils
iront défendre l'euro 2016 et les
golfeurs
ça se joue entre le louis versailles qui
est juste sur l'avenue du château et le
et le trianon un peu plus loin sur des
sur des critères de sur des critères de
choix d'installations existantes et de
savoir ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
compléter complété pour le pour être
quand vraiment camp de base grande base
hébergement pour les pour les gallois
alors avant de refermer cette page un
rappel la coupe du monde de rugby sera
donc programmé à gré vous disiez du 8
septembre au 28 octobre 2023 en france
on a déjà hâte d'y être un j'imagine
pierre
alors maintenant ouvrir une page course
à pied si vous adorez faire des courses
on peut le dire il ya de quoi faire dans
l'est le département des yvelines
dernièrement le 19 mars dernier il y a
eu l'écho trail de paris une course qui
est partie de l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines pour le 80 km ou du
château de versailles pour le 45 km une
semaine plus tard il ya eu là
pisciacaise une course de 10 km en
pleine nature qui a attiré plusieurs
centaines de personnes et le calendrier
s'emballe dans le département avec
l'arrivée des beaux jours en avril il y
aura la diac 78 laguillon course le
trail du josas le trail de guerville le
rambo littrell et des dizaines de rendez
vous d'ici les vacances estivales bref
vous l'aurez compris il ya de quoi faire
il ya beaucoup de formules du 10km à lui
à 13 la question sur cette thématique
est ce qu'il n'ya pas trop de courses
dans les yvelines non pour vous genre
non pour vous michael n'ont pas de débat
non plus
mon passage à travers la thématique
genre jose a été le premier à
soulever votre pancartes oui c'était au
hasard c'était un certain assez bas mais
non c'est pas vrai non j'ai dit non
pourquoi parce que il n'ya jamais assez
et a jamais assez ce soit en bus des
compétitions qui regroupe énormément de
participants les courses à pied tout ce
qui est autour la course à pied il ya de
plus en plus de deux catégories il ya
les les trahit les eco trail et il est
déçu marathon les cross normaux il ya de
plus en plus de catégories donc
forcément il va justement super je pense
pas puisque les jacks dû pratiquer les
catégories en question bombay elles
savent pertinemment ce qu'ils ont à
faire il s'entraîne pour et il ya en
plus c'est un mélange de deux sportifs
confirmés et de sportifs loisirs et ça
c'est très bien parce que c'est vraiment
de sport populaire qui demande peu
d'investissements financiers et qui
demande qui kiffent qui saute très
excellente pour la santé le bien-être
que ce soit physique mental il ya tout
tout tout tout tout et est représenté
sade est simple voilà exactement il a et
donc on n'a pas encore vu pire garder le
voilà on l'a pas encore à l'image
donc je dois le voir dans un instant
voit la santé est simple voilà c'est
pour ça que c'est pour ça que je dis que
non non lorsqu'il agit n'ya jamais assez
de compétitions de ce genre mike weir au
delà de la réponse de gens que je
partage fondamentalement on a une
population qui est maintenant beaucoup
plus sédentaires donc faire du sport à
tous les niveaux moi je pense que c'est
forcément une bonne chose en plus on a
vécu le confinement ya pas longtemps
donc voilà redonner à tous ces sportifs
l'envi de sortir d'aller dehors de faire
du sport et on connaît l'importance du
sport pour la santé pour le moral pour
le stress enfin pour tous et non moins
houleux moi je peux qu'encourager sa
pierre sortait santé cendrillon cours et
de temps en temps moi je cours de temps
en temps à essayer ça m'apporte un d
c'est un des points que je voulais
aborder c'est que c'est l'aspect
challenge l'aspect chalon de succès
quelles que soient les âges finalement
jeunes et surtout moins jeunes quand on
quand on commence à quitter les sports
un peu plus de contact ou un petit peu
plus punchy
on se retrouve à plusieurs à quai à
trois ou quatre à se fixer un défi nous
c'était à 12 pour aller courir le
marathon de new york s'est pas trop on
ne sait pas trop mon gabarit au départ
mais j'ai adoré le préparer ou les films
et le finir et le feeling encore
maintenant 16h55
et d avoir ce type de ce type de
challenge je trouve que la course à pied
c'est dont les gens le le jean et
michael le rappeler c'est un c'est déjà
un sport qui favorise la santé de toute
façon il y aura jamais suffisamment
d'activités sportives qui permettent aux
uns et aux autres d'éviter d'être
sédentaire et de faire justement
régulièrement du sport parce qu'on sait
que c'est bon c'est bon pour le pour le
coeur pour la santé en général moins bon
pour les articulations certes mais s'il
y a suffisamment de de matériel
maintenant pour pouvoir des bonnes
running d'ailleurs pour pouvoir
s'aligner sur des courts de 2,2 me fous
de fond est simple c'est que il ya
besoin d'une paire de running un short
un short et éventuellement à aux
techniques on quand on s'entraîne divers
par exemple mais du wes adultes a du
courage sa session pour se mettre le
coup de pied aux fesses pour y aller
mais il y en aura jamais assez est la
preuve c'est qu'on sait qu'en gros il ya
de l'intérêt ne se tarit pas il ya
toujours de plus en plus de monde sur
toutes les courses et jeannot parler
delà de la diversité d'activités on
rajoute le mode d ce genre de ce genre
de ce genre de d'événements qui sont
fans en plus qui sont vraiment fait le
caller rhône où il n'y a ni plan social
pour halloween aussi à poissy je crois
je crois qu'on a les images le trait le
oui non c'était pas les autres et
l'obésité donc les sous c'était aux
clayes-sous-bois là c'est tout
simplement une course pour halloween à
poissy on les voit
les enfants et les adultes tous que ce
qui est important de préciser c'est que
sur sur tout c est toujours les églises
r bien sûr il y en a il y en a beaucoup
de nouvelles un plus de plus en plus de
villes très récemment la ville
d'elancourt a créé son élan courte
championne strikes se mettent aussi à
créer des courses parce qu'il ya eu une
envie aussi de se retrouver on a parlé
du confinement et de tout le monde qui a
été chez soi là il ya une envie de se
retrouver plusieurs courses aussi qui
sont proposées pour tous les niveaux moi
je pense qu'il ya trois avantages il
al'avantage aussi le côté de montrer
toute la richesse du département ce qui
est bien c'est comme si on a des courses
sur les parcours qui sont totalement
différentes on a des parcours urbains
des parcours ruraux des parcours en
forêt ve voilà y'a vraiment pour tous
les goûts il ya des courses de très haut
niveau une création récente c'est la
diagonale des yvelines vous avez parlé
aussi de l'eco-trail qui attire des
coureurs de très haut niveau il ya
nicolas du high qui a gagné les
cauterets qui a été aussi sur d'autres
courses dans les yvelines il ya celui
qu'on appelle casquette verte alexandre
boucher ex qui est connu dans le milieu
du trail et qui vient aussi courir dans
les études je sais pas pourquoi de mes
camarades rigole mais c'est pas grave
puisque et et ça a été dit par jean je
crois
le côté aussi tous les niveaux ce qui
est bien c'est que ça s'adresse à des
coureurs de haut niveau mais sur
d'autres compétitions d'autres courses
ya plusieurs formats ça va pouvoir aussi
s'ouvrir aux amateurs qui ont envie de
se dépasser de se fixer un objectif un
tiers de course en plus dans les
yvelines depuis 2000 les années 2000
mais c'est normal c'est une cc liée
aussi elle dit à la diversité des offres
si on prend d'autres d'autres sports
individuels comme par exemple le golfe
où il ya eu neuf 9 trous énormes 18
trous la course à pied c'est séduit à du
5km du 10 km il ya du vin qui les 21 km
pour les semi marathon marathon très il
a eu 30 60 80 bornes les 100 km de
millau il ya tout les mêmes pour les
enfants des ensembles et lommel de
kilomètres et voir les enfants voir les
enfants ils sont surmotivés quand il a
une petite course comme ça et qui est à
leur niveau et qui est à l'heure
inquiète alors oui à leurs niveaux de
pouvoir de pouvoir finir un kilomètre de
kilomètres l'important c'est terminé au
lieu au lieu de au lieu de participer
qui reste le le principe olympiques mais
justement terminé et il ya toutes les
offres pour le faire dans la question
est-ce que c'est pas une mode est-ce que
vous pensez que ça va durer votre avis
mike
est cette effervescence autour de la
course à pied j'espère pas thaler comme
j'ai dit on a une population qui est
sédentaire donc ça veut dire qu'on
n'aime pas faire beaucoup de sport et il
faut justement le drainé dans l'esprit
de tous les enfants de tout le monde de
faire du sport parce que c'est vraiment
un effet bénéfique pour la santé pour le
corps et pour tous donc donc voila moi
j'espère que ça va pas être quelque
chose d'éphémère savent quelque chose
qui va perdurer dans le temps parce que
le sport c'est important pour tout le
monde et les statistiques dont le
démontrer encore plusieurs fois que
c'est vraiment important on va
maintenant très rapidement efira liège a
confirmé ce que disent ébahis qu'en
diront confirmant que qu'a priori si ça
avait dû
être un effet de mode ça ferait
longtemps que rake qui aurait plu autant
de courses divers et variés que
justement c'est un intérêt kid qui ne se
tarit pas et qu'ils appellent de plus en
plus de sportifs du dimanche mais ou pro
ou amateur et qui qui répond présent à
chaque avec chacune des courses on verra
l'année prochaine sur le marathon new
york
c'est d'aller paris marle dimanche pour
cela je lui confiais pour défier vous
interroger ce type d'émission
alors maintenant parler d'une histoire
qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre ces
derniers jours le footballeur du psg
quillanais mbappé a refusé de participer
à une opération publicitaire avec
l'équipe de france lors du rassemblement
des bleus à clairefontaine centre
d'entraînement situé dans les yvelines
et la contester la convention relative à
la cession du droit collectif à l'image
normalement chaque international la
signe avant sa première sélection elle
contient des obligations vis-à-vis de la
fff en échange de cet engagement chaque
joueur reçoit 25000 euros environ par
matches disputés l'avocat de killem bape
et delphine verheyden estime que le
joueur doit être en harmonie avec des
publicités auquel il participe car ce
sont des modèles pour le public il ya
aussi le côté à financiers dans ce
contrat qui pose problème le joueur 7
son droit à l'image sur la question sur
cette thématique comprenez vous ce
boycott de killian m bape et chiens oui
ou non
partagez vous êtes tous partagé ou wii
pour vous le comprenez ce boycott bons
vacances et par vaux bike alors moi je
le comprends tout dépend en fait comme
on veut
on veut répondre
je comprends très bien la situation mais
après je parle par rapport au public
tous les gens qui regardent ces
discussions là
ce qui est important c'est les sportifs
en général on leur demande pas leur avis
on demande à un sportif par exemple de
d'être un bon joueur de bien représenter
son pays un bape et représente la france
il représente la france de par sa
manière de se comporter de parler dans
les médias de manger toutes ces choses
là et puis après derrière on à
l'institution ces personnalités
publiques pour exactement six nations
c'est une personnalité publique et
apprête à l'institution qui est l'équipe
de france qui signent des partenariats
avec a et c
coca cola et après on demande aux
joueurs de représenter la nation d'une
bonne manière là il ya pour moi ya pas
une cohérence par rapport à ça et mba p
c'est quelqu'un qui est droit dans ses
bottes il sait ce qu'il fait et on l'a
vu dans plusieurs choses en général la
cohérence dans tout ce qu'il fait et
pour lui représenté coca cola kfc toutes
ces choses là ça ne lui parle pas vous
l'avez bien inciter au départ sur sur
vos analyses ils représentent d'autres
marques qui sont plutôt de de sa manière
de voir les choses en général et est de
ce fait là c'est une contradiction
produit donc moi je trouve ça tout à
fait légitime de mieux réagir notamment
la publicité pour la nourriture bio pour
enfants exactement et puis après mois -
là où je trouve ça un peu compliqué
cesser ses partenaires parce qu'ils
savent très bien ce qui se passe ce qui
se joue à ce niveau là ce qui est un peu
dommage a pour lui un bape et c2c de
prendre des décisions comme ça de
manière individuelle et ça ça peut lui
une porté préjudice un petit peu en
général c'est mieux d'agir de manière
collective pour avoir une réponse
collective parce que là on parle de
l'équipe de france on parle d'un débat
qui concerne tous les joueurs de
l'équipe de france et je pense pas que
les autres joueurs pensent pas moins du
ska p vient de dire moi je pense que la
plupart des joueurs pensent la même
chose mais simplement excusez moi du
terme mais ils n'ont pas les couilles de
sortir là
les médias est de gagner et de l'arrivée
carton jaune pour vous dire la vérité
montant gauche donc donc donc voilà
pourquoi je suis mitigé par rapport à ça
et puis approche delà de ça il ya aussi
un phénomène le football c'est un
vecteur important pour la société et à
travers coca cola on peut
instrumentaliser les choses à travers
les jeunes enfants depuis le bas âge
jusqu'à un certain âge et on sait que
coca cola kfc tous ces choses là c'est
pas bon pour la nutrition quand soient
sportifs de haut niveau pas pour moi
c'est des choses comme il faut regarder
ça des divisions enfin des niveaux
différents
genres je sais que vous avez quelque
chose à dire sur la question à une fois
je crois que vous allez soutenir qu'il
ya un bp
oui et non oui non non on en est
conscient que j'étais un petit peu je
rejouais je rejoins jusqu'à dix mike sur
le jeu reprend pas ce qu'il a dit
puisqu'il vient de là où je rejoins en
tout les cas par contre ensuite ce ce
sont des joueurs professionnels y signe
un contrat professionnel donc dans la
mesure où il signe ce contrat ils ont
justement la teneur du contrat et se
voit dans l'obligation de respecter ce
contrat parce que sinon ce sont des
joueurs professionnels je dis je le
répète sinon vous tient contrat vous
essayez autre contrat professionnel à
dire attention sauf que moi moi ça je le
fais pas ça non non ça je veux bien
faire le boulot là mais c'est cette
partie du boulot je fais pas non c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible aussi un
contrat il est lisible s'il n'est pas
d'accord mais il ne signait pas il va
pas l'étude de phrases aussi bons qu'ils
soient mais on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas prendre que ce qui nous arrange ou
ce qui fait plaisir à quelqu'un alors
c'est pas qui fait plaisir parce que là
en l'occurrence l'institution fait la
même chose oui mais non mais c'est là où
ses contradicteurs ma vie parce que si
je suis une institution c'est moi qui
égaieront après je suis garant de serre
c'est oui bon c'est quand même on sait
qu'un qu' ils ne vivent pas ils ne
vivent pas avec le avec l'air du temps
et il ne veut pas d'amour et d'eau
fraîche donc on sait pertinemment que le
nerf de la guerre c'est l'argent c'est
l'argent et que tout tourne et que ses
contrats publicitaires si ce qui amène
l'argent et chris kaman énormément
d'argent je suis dans le milieu du foot
avec ça donc de là le diaboliser à dire
que c'est c'est dingue ce qu'il est en
train de faire une balle en jeu
c'est bon ça c'est en général par
rapport à ça parce que c'est
l'institution comme ça et c'est pour ça
que je suis une partie d'accord avec lui
mais une autre partie je suis pas
d'accord parce que il a signé un contrat
pro et on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
choisir c'est pas c'est pas la carte je
ne sais pas la carte il a signé le même
contrat que l'ensemble des joueurs de
l'équipe de france qui arrive la région
qui est né en 2010 après nice maintenant
que ce n'est pas la carte on ne peut pas
se permettre on veut pas ouvrir la porte
aussi d'un autre côté en disant vous
faites ce que vous voulez vous vous
prenez les plus que vous voulez celle
qui vous arrache de celles qui vous
plaisent non c'est pas possible sans la
bouger c'est là où je dis voilà c'est là
que je dis il faut parler avec les
athlètes pour trouver un accord ensemble
parce que l'institution les athlètes de
l'autre côté du chenal au final mike
tous les sponsors c'est ce qui donne le
plus d'argent ils sont choisis besuelle
ce qu'on va demander aux athlètes
de signer de tels ou tels contrats de
relance ce n'est pas leur rôle
logiquement on leur demande de jouer
c'est pas eux qui font les contrats
publicitaires mais fait à titre veut à
titre de l'équipe de france a dit
gregory le sol oublié depuis tout à
l'heure quand j'avais envie de
participer ce qui était dit non mais oui
bien sûr j'ai envie de participer à ce
débat je comprends le postulat départ de
ken maps et de dire ses sponsors ne
véhicule pas l'image que je souhaite
véhiculer que c'est contraire aussi
peut-être à l'éthique du sport à l'image
que doit renvoyer le un sport comme
comme le football ça je peux le
comprendre le postulat de départ il ya
aussi un autre argument qui a été avancé
par son avocate c'est que c'est ce
contrat cette convention a été signée
avant la première sélection ça c'est
important de le préciser c'est à dire
que kilian d'apella signe en 2010 est
juste ans sa première sélection c'est un
contrat qui court jusqu'à la fin de leur
parcours en bleu il n'y a jamais de
renégociation possible donc s'il reste
jusqu'à ses 45 ans en équipe de france
tu devras doit respecter ce qu'on suivre
maintenant là où je suis partagé où je
rejoins
jeannot c'est que effectivement il a
signé ce contrat et il doit le respecter
il ya des manquements normalement s'il
ya des manquements à ce contrat il ya
des sanctions qui sont prévus dans par
par par l'équipe de france visiblement
noël le graet le président de la
fédération française de football a dit
qu'il était contre les sanctions et
qu'il ya deux maps et ne sera pas
suspendu et c'est un sport un précédent
le problème c'est que maintenant on va
se retrouver dans une situation où
peut-être d'autres joueurs vont
contester vont profiter du courage que
mba paix a eu parce que c'est peut-être
aussi du courage pour dire non nous on
ne se soustraient pas à ces opérations
commerciales mais il ya un problème dans
l'air c'est que ça rapporte énormément
d'argent à la fédération française de
football je m'étais noté de montant de
108 millions d'euros et ce montant est
largement
redistribuer vers le football amateur
donc il ya aussi un problème qui est
suscitée par parce par ce boycott donc à
mon sens le vrai problème c'est que sa
plainte serait un précédent et ça peut
donner des idées à d'autres joueurs et
là on va se retrouver dans une ville à
moitié des parts de quelque sens mais ça
peut être aussi dans d'autres sélections
ça peut être aussi dans d'autres
sélections effectivement dire je vais
lire mon partage c'est le premier point
qui me fait que je ne comprends pas
c'est le même que j'en ai et mike ces
jeux les vaincus c'est le point de vue
juridique il a signé le contrat il doit
il doit le respecter c'est ceci étant
dit parra par tout le monde derrière il
ya une épée 25000 euros par match se
disent qu'il faut rappeler c'est que
c'est que elle m'appelle lui reverse
aussi une bonne partie de ces de ses
revenus d'image à dézoner à des
associations caritatives dont qu'il est
vraiment il est là d'or jusqu'au
boutiste redondance et dans ses
positions là où je voudrais
insister c'est ce qui me ce qui me fait
le comprendre dans cette dans cette
décision là c'est le nouveau statut de
kylie ann m bape et en équipe de france
et au psg qu'il est en train d'acquérir
et qui va garder je pense un grand
nombre d'années parce que parce que ce
champion là il est là pour de nombreuses
années c'est un monstre sportif
technique c'est une pépite comme on en a
qu une fois dans l'histoire d'une équipe
nationale peut être parce que même
thierry henry n'avait pas n'avait pas
ses stats là il n'avait pas 7-7 ce côté
complet de la tête français c'est un
jeune garçon qui s'exprime bien
qui est bien entouré qui a la tête sur
les épaules qui je suis je vais rentrer
dans le cliché je vais me mettre à dos
le football football français si c'est
étonnant de voir un voir un footballeur
s'exprimer comme ça et raisonner comme
ça évidemment tous les footballeurs ne
sont ne sont pas linverse je dis pas ça
parce que tu es libre date de la sortie
du studio avec ce statut là qui est qui
et qui sentent à pour de nombreuses
années
effectivement il crée un précédent parce
que il prend pour lui et il gère lui
même grâce à son conseil son image mais
avec en plus des désirs des niveaux de
réflexion qu'on avait encore jamais vu à
ce niveau là vient de dire de dire que
là que cette marque là n'est pas
conforme à ses convictions
je n'ai jamais entendu un international
français parlé de ça vous vous rappeliez
que ces contrats la ctcc de certains de
2010 après le fiasco de deux nièces nice
n'a et l'afrique du sud là maintenant
mais est-ce que c'est pas de plus en
plus dans l'air du temps mais je pense
par exemple à cristiano ronaldo qui
pendant le dernier euro avait par
exemple enlever une bouteille de coca
d'une conférence de presse de l'euro il
avait fait perdre
1,6 pour cent de la valeur de la marque
à la bourse de new york en faisant juste
ce geste d'enlever cette marque de coca
en dise enfin cette bouteille de coca
cola en disant pas de sodas de l'eau
responsable donc c'est pas forcément le
doute
et des sportifs de haut niveau et parmi
les parmi les plus grandes stars du
monde parle de cristiano ronaldo de
killian mbappé et c'est maintenant et
ses 7,7 maintenant cette médiatisation
dont ils bénéficient ou qui leur pèse
éventuellement sur certains moments ils
sont ils sont maintenant ils sont ce
sont nos nouveau porte drapeau sur
n'importe quelle cause et parce que
finalement ils ont maintenant
l'institution finalement marine
justement ce à inverser les rôles on le
voit aux états unis en louant une bille
est aussi là je parle d'un autre
contexte mais c'est la même chose et
aujourd'hui mvp vous prônez cette image
là comme tu l'a bien précisé c'est
nicole mondial maintenant mba paix et
tout le monde ici à signer des contrats
sur ses tables là mais à un moment donné
quand tu évolues tu regardes ton contrat
pour revoir qu'est ce qui peut changer
au poids et un bape et c'est un gars qui
est intelligent il a eu une démarche
justement dans ce sens là mais sauf que
la fédération n'a pas voulu changer les
termes du contrat et à un moment donné
que se positionne parce que quelque part
il véhicule cette image là il a envie de
montrer l'exemple donc moi je pense
qu'il faut essayer de l'accompagner tout
soit trouvé quelque chose de cohérent
pour tout le monde et puis c'est d'aller
dans le bon sens qui est dit des faux
frères planel mangeant à votre avis
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire mais c'est
compliqué c'est très compliqué parce que
il a une démarche qui cette démarche qui
a
explosé un peu le système sauf qu'il est
il est partie intégrante d'un sport
collectif il n'est pas aisé il ne
pratique pas un sport individuel c'est
pas du symbole par exemple usain bolt
qui lui faisait ce qu'il voulait là il
est dans du vin dans un cadre collectif
et c'est là le problème c'est là comment
fait-on là le fait que le président ne
prenne pas de sanction il ouvre la porte
à tout le monde mais c'est à dire que la
dengue moi ça va enclencher la
discussion ab savalas kg ils vont
peut-être montagneux et peu des
responsables vont se retirer aussi un
jeu rappelait sauf ce partenaire
officiel un kfc coca cola de la brioche
pasquier edf pmu car fois quand 21 h
gregory dahl a rappelé tout à l'heure 5
millions d'heureux qui pour la plupart
sont répartis 87 87 voilà donc sur le
sport amateur donc attention parce qu'on
dit on dit on dit le professionnalisme
ne l'était même pas sur le sport amateur
là pour une fois qu'il intervient de
façon large on doit peut-être se tirer
une balle dans le pied coup c'est ça le
problème c'est ça
j'ai envie de compléter quelque chose
quand même dans ce cas là si on veut
rester dans cette pédagogie là où ses
démarches ce fonctionnement là quand un
athlète de haut niveau fait des erreurs
il faut aussi le lui pardonner parce que
des fois un athlète de haut niveau il a
pas le bon comportement il parle pas
bien il est ceci et cela c'est la fin du
monde l'institution a le droit de faire
certaines choses que l'on peut lui
pardonner mais l'athlète de haut niveau
c'est pas le cas c'est là où je trouve
que je sais pas si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire le débat le forcené un bleu il
est pas il n'est pas équitable un moment
donné faut respecter tout le monde un
sportif de haut niveau ça reste une
personne comme tout le monde dans le
sens où il peut être faillible à un
moment donné l'institution peut être
aussi fine donc il faut essayer de
regarder les choses dans les deux ans
une gré parlé tout à l'heure de ce
contrat initial avant la première
sélection et qui en plus n'est pas
retouché endroits et notamment au droit
du travail on ressort le contrat quand
ça se passe mal quand ça va mal et on
regarde ce qui est donc là pour une fois
le conseil et qu'il ya dan dah les mêmes
maps et ont dû peut-être anticipé ce
moment là et on dire ou es ce que est ce
que est ce qu'on a le droit votre
guillemets de boycotter ou de toute
façon la créer un précédent et peut-être
ouvrir les discussions pour la
négociation ce type de contrat
effectivement il y aura un avant et un
après cette sortie de ce type de ce type
de situation mais je pense que c'est le
laura et le nouveau statut de kilian est
mbappé qui lui a permis de le faire
les gorilles est close a rajouté juste
complété à titre d'information pour dire
que cette convention elle va au delà
quand même aussi du partenariat
commercial c'est aussi une charte de
bonne conduite pour les joueurs en
équipe de france parce que on rappelle
le contexte ça a été juste après nice
taille et ce moment très trouble pour le
football français mais aussi vis-à-vis
des partenaires sont ambitieuses en plus
de participer à des opérations de
sponsors c'est aussi pour le joueur au
moins une fois dans la saison allez
assister à un entraînement avec des
amateurs ou participer à des soirées
justement avec les partenaires donc
c'est une convention qui était assez
globale qui peut peut-être poser
problème sur certains points et c'est
pour ça peut être que kilian bape et se
positionne aujourd'hui contre contre
cette convention on pourrait en parler
pendant des heures de cette histoire de
2 km à pied mais malheureusement on va
devoir passer notre dernière thématique
c'est notre page débats
[Musique]
dans cette page débat nous allons parler
d'une confession rares à celle du
handballeur évinois à valentin porte le
natif de versailles et capitaine de
l'équipe de france à renoncer à
rassemblement des bleus suite à des
problèmes personnels sa femme est partie
au retour de l'eau en janvier dernier ce
qui l'a obligé à suivre une thérapie
pour essayer de gérer la situation une
thérapie qui joue sur sa santé mentale
actuelle il se dit même angoissé à
l'idée de rejoindre l'équipe de france
la thérapeute lui a parlé d'une déprime
qui peut se transformer en dépression
on entend beaucoup parler de santé
mentale en ce moment dans le monde du
sport handball football tennis ou
gymnastique la question sur ce thème la
santé mentale était là votre avis encore
un tabou dans le monde du sport
oui ou non parce que c'est encore un
tabou oui pour vous my wii pour vous
jean louis pour vos pierres et non pour
vous
tout à l'heure j'ai pas
mes centres
alors pierre pour vous pour vous ce
n'est plus un tabou sa soixante ans
c'est encore un tabou c'est con non plus
que tabou sur le sur le mot c'est qu'on
veut c'est qu'on n'en parle pas
suffisamment et on n'anticipe pas
suffisamment le potentiel mal-être de la
plupart des athlètes le ski est plus
proche de nous de nous augmenter en
termes d'intérêts c'est c'la les
tragédies qui sont arrivés à deux ans
d'intervalle à de rugbyman professionnel
christophe dominici et j'aurais niche
aller à rouen national rugby euros
normandie rugby pardon
avec des
10 déjà l'étape ultime la plus tragique
où les où les joueurs on est de se
mettre fin à leurs jours
et que personne même pas leurs proches
n'avait vu venir donc il ya plein de
raisons sur l'équipe d'ailleurs que
j'ignore notamment dans le cas de
christophe dominici beaucoup de choses
qui se sont écrites et notamment
récemment sur sur l'opération avortée à
béziers etc qui l'avait beaucoup affecté
de là à aller au bout de cette démarche
de mal être il ya quand même quelque
chose qui cloche et dont dont il faut
parler pour éviter les tabous et
justement faire en sorte que les
sportifs de haut niveau puissent en
parler puis se confier quand il est
content quand il ya des comptes ya des
cas comme celui là dans le cadre
valentin porte c'est un cas personnel
qui de coeur est qui et qui affecte sa
vie d'homme de père peut-être et 2 et 2
et d'athlètes et en l'occurrence c'est
et il en parle je crois dans ma mémoire
en tout cas si je puise je crois que
c'est le premier à parler de ce type
d'initiative mais je pense aussi que ça
va ça va qu'un
suivi une thérapie pour reconstruire de
médiatisation il ya déjà des médias télé
télé radio maintenant il ya les réseaux
sociaux et il ya un certain nombre
d'expositions qui font du bien comme ils
font du mal aussi et là pour le coup les
athlètes ne peuvent quasiment plus
planté et se planquer se planter 6 mai
se planquer et notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux ça va assez vite a démonté un à
tête parce que il a fait une seconde de
moins sur son sur son temps de référence
par exemple ou alors qu'il a acquis là
qu'il a foiré un but à un moment où
c'était c'était important donc oui la
danger danger ils sont exposés le mental
fait quasiment tout quand le physique
flanche donc alerte le gens c'est encore
tabou
oui pour moi je reprends parce que du
pire a dit
bien sûr c'est encore tabou et le fait
que un sportif de haut niveau comme
valentin porte en parle ça va être aussi
donner
la possibilité à d'autres de pouvoir
s'exprimer et de franchir le cap parce
que justement le mental sur les joueurs
de haut niveau c'est très important il
est très très important c'est ce qui
fait la différence
souvent parce qu'on dit qu'est-ce qui
fait les grands champions c'est le
mental donc cette différence qui fait
qui fait les grands champions fait aussi
en sens inverse la différence parce que
lorsqu'ils sont au fond du seau bas ils
le sont peut-être encore plus parce que
justement ils ont le mental qui est
puissante qui est qui et qui a au niveau
comme comme leurs performances physiques
et ils montrent autant avec leur mental
qui peuvent descendre aussi bas là le
fait qu'ils en parlent c'est déjà un
grand pas
c'est un grand pas parce que là on ne se
taira peux te le dis que ça peut amener
jusqu'à jusqu'à une dépression mais je
suis pas trop le milieu médical mais il
me semble quand même qu'une dépression
justement on ne sait pas vraiment de
quoi tout cas séduit une dépression on
sait que on constate à la fin qu'on est
en dépression mais le motif vraiment
pour lequel on ne le dit pas voilà ma
femme s'est barré je suis en dépression
ou non ça n'existe pas c'est un état
général qui fait qu' on se retrouve on
n'a plus goût à rien que s'il claque
qu'on est au fond du seau et le fait
d'en parler c'est déjà tendant la main
c'est déjà dire voilà au secours et ça
je pense que ce mental de sportive de
haut niveau fait qu'il a eu le courage
de temps dans la même parce qu'il ya
aussi ce côté pudeur ce côté dire
dévoilé dévoilé une partie de sa vie
privée pierre l'a dit avec tous les
réseaux sociaux cas au tour mais là lui
l'a quand même s'il y en a qui l'ont
soutenu et
d'autres qui surtout d'une huile ont
rigolé à la voile sur la nouvelle et
c'est pour ça et c'est pour ça donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faut avoir un gros
mental un très gros mental dans ce dans
ce cas de figure pour justement tendre
la main et dire au secours au secours et
des mots parce que c'est ça c'est un
appel au secours et moi je dis que c'est
archi pas tout il ya encore une fois
mais c'est celle aguérris une partie de
la guérison keita marche pour moi
grégory sinon entièrement d'accord sur
cet aspect là je pense que le plus
important maintenant c'est aussi les
athlètes je pense on a un rôle dans ce
sujet là qui est qui encore tabou ça je
suis d'accord avec ça c'est d'en parler
justement ce que on l'a vu dans d'autres
affaires mais mort du sport le fait de
parler ça va libérer juste ans dans la
parole d'autres personnes qui ont
peut-être vécu des dépressions dans le
monde du sport on le voit pas forcément
parce que on voit des surhommes des sur
femmes c'est un peu des super héros les
sportifs et on ne peut pas penser que
derrière il ya un humain derrière cette
carapace et qui peut aussi subir des
dépressions donc ça c'est un aspect
important et moi je pense que l'année
2000 21 a été pour moi un tournant je
pense que vous vouliez parler de saimone
bynes
calorifique voilà la plus grande
gymnastes peut-être de l'histoire à
lamelles sont des mots dgi.un sûr sûr
sûr les réseaux sociaux n'a pas pu
s'aligner sur des épreuves pendant les
derniers jo de tokyo pour se concentrer
sur sa santé mentale c'était ses mots se
concentrer sur sa santé mentale ça fait
seulement une finale et une médaille de
bronze au final elle a été victime aussi
d'abus sexuels aussi dans sa jeunesse
aussi ça a été révélée a juste avant à
la compétition c'était peut-être le
symbole peut-être cette centrale à se
déroule pendant le plus grand événement
sportif à une surexposition tout le
monde en a parlé et là forcément c'est
on s'est posé à les questions il ya des
études qui sont sortis il ya une étude
très récente qui a dit que 80% des
sportifs professionnels en france avait
au moment un moment dans leur carrière
ressenti une fatigue anormale un moment
de tristesse un moment de moins bien
donc ça peut conduire aussi sur cet état
de dépression en parler c'est important
mais il ya un exemple qui me vient en
tête parce que je suis un amoureux du
football italien le sportif que moi j'ai
apprécié qui qui a été un peu une forme
d' idole pour moi gianluigi bouffonne a
vécu une dépression dans les années 2000
il en a parlé qu'en 2017 mais même ça
dont on parle est bien là bien après ça
montre que à ce moment là personne s'est
rendu compte qu'il avait vécu une
dépression est donc le plus important
pour moi c'est d'en parler
et ça les fera peut-être des tabous ça
sauvera peut-être des vies parce qu'il
ya aussi tous ces sportifs qui après
avoir arrêté leur sport tombe s'il ya
des exemples dans l'alcoolisme parfois
même dans dans des choses encore plus
grave et non je pense que c'est
important de libérer la parole et de
pouvoir en parler michael vous qui êtes
sportif
sportifs de haut niveau qu'est ce que
vous en pensez tout d'abord je pense
qu'on a toujours deux casquettes
qu'est-ce qu'elle de sportifs de haut
niveau et puis aussi on a une personne à
part entière et on ne peut pas dissocier
les deux de ce fait là
s'il se passe quelque chose dans notre
vie personnelle forcément ça peut
impacter dans le performance et on fait
du sport de haut niveau nous demandent
de la performance mais au-delà de ça il
ya des personnes qui sont adaptés à des
personnes qui sont là qui font ce métier
là pour accompagner ses adeptes et moi
je pense que c'est quelque chose qu'ils
doivent se faire davantage parce que en
présente les sportifs comme des super
héros oui c'est des super héros dans ce
qu'ils font à un moment donné c'est des
êtres humains ils sont faillibles il
peut faire des erreurs et j'ai
l'impression que les sportifs de haut
niveau ne peuvent pas faire d'erreur et
ça c est c moi je trouve ça ni mal il
faut enlever ça c'est une lettre c'est
un être humain à part entière comme tout
le monde il fait quelque chose de
magnifique comme toutes les autres
personnes qui fondent d'autres métiers
différents mais c'est des personnes à
part entière et donc de ce fait là il
faut les accompagner il faut accompagner
toutes ces personnes qui traversent ces
moments là et on l'a vu un patrice evra
aussi qu'il ya eu des déclarations aussi
kobe bryant tony parker enfin sa
séparation avec sa fin et c'est des
choses qui joue forcément sur la
performance donc non voilà il faut avoir
un côté humain et puis à des gens qui
parlent souvent de ces athlètes mais ils
ont même pas pratiquer un sport de haut
niveau et un moment donné il faut
essayer d'avoir un côté un peu humaniste
je trouve dans ces situations là par les
communications indirectement avec
p et soyez son contrat là le dit il faut
il faut juste se rappeler que à l'époque
où on vit ou qui est surexposé
surmédiatisée les athlètes de haut
niveau hommes femmes ce sont également
des hommes et des femmes et qui
apprennent maintenant à communiquer sur
leur vie d'homme sur la vie de femme que
ça aille bien où ça fait mal on les voit
beaucoup quand ça va bien là c'est une
parole qui se libère avec avec valentin
porte et qui souhaitons le effectivement
nous permettra à ceux qui sont un petit
peu dans le creux de la vague de pouvoir
de pouvoir s'exprimer et éviter les
drames et certains craquent complètement
la vue avec naomi osaka par exemple qui
a craqué pendant le un match à indian
wells et bien ça comme on commet elle
explique sa là par contre c'est aux yeux
de tout le monde finalement
7 ce mal être comme il l'a dit jean des
fois il ya d'autres personnes qui se
servent de ça pour exceller on l'a vu
kobe bryant il avait perdu sa femme
enfin divorce parce que les histoires de
tromperies toutes ces choses là il a
utilisé sa pour performer et après tu as
d'autres personnes ou salées en terre
donc encore une fois le côté mental qui
joue donc ça dépend de tout un chacun de
nos sensibilités voilà j'en voulais
rajouter quelque chose
oui j'ai une pensée pour tiger woods qui
lui aussi a eu certains problèmes dans
sa carrière et mentalement il a eu là
aussi le courage d'en parler
suite à ces déviances un petit peu
day out celui qui a qui est du coup
devenu redevenu ce champion malgré tout
ce qu'il a tout ce qu'il a vécu et
l'iran
déjà vachement que c'est ça aussi la
base ce sont des hommes et des femmes ou
les pro
aubry très rarement notifiés sur la
préparation mentale toi dans ta carrière
s'il y'en y en a eu on a puisque lé
préparateur mental j'en ai fait j'ai
fait la sophrologie aussi savoir gérer
l'énergie l'énergie négative s'est pris
en compte bien sûr ces messieurs parce
que encore une fois l'image du sportif
toujours bien véhiculé tout ce qui fait
ça en faisait partie mais effectivement
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission a
terminé comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui je vous propose une
citation de l'ancien président du club
de football de montpellier louis
nicollin
mes fils je préfère qu'ils soient nés
dans le sport plutôt que dans la musique
classique parce que ça ça me fait chier
j'ai rien contre mais je préfère
regarder un match de curling qu écouter
du mozart je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase sur tv 78
[Musique]
on